bringing bill plash key LA Times
columnist and of course contributor to
around the horn you want to settle this
bill number one team in town is that the
Dodgers or the Lakers
it's the Lakers and it's not even close
right now it's the Lakers by far yeah
they've really just in the past several
years I know the Dodgers doctors because
of their TV you know a lot of people
came and see him on TV so they get
people get excited about them in October
when they can watch him on TV but other
than that and no it's the Lakers they've
captured of the acute swath of community
as the Kobe Bryant mourning and grieving
a period has shown in one is I'm curious
about this team and the makeup of this
team with what happened with Kobe as
they move on you know some teams when
there's tragedy it empowers them and
Boldin's them where others they get sort
of dwarfed by something like this the
makeup of this Laker team any concerns
about this as they move forward yeah
yeah that's a great question yeah I
don't think we know yet I think LeBron
really stepped up big Friday I mean in
my mind he became a Laker on Friday with
his five-minute speech to the fans he
was really engaged and connected and
really had all the right notes but they
you know then I stated what I'm playing
Sacramento and they have a huge Kobe
tribute there there's gonna be there's
gonna be Kobe tributes every place they
play this year and I don't think we know
how much that's going to weigh on them
they have this happen again and again
and again I think they'll be fine
because again because I think LeBron is
taking them on this mission on his
shoulders in a way that I haven't seen
before and he's really again he's really
become part of the part of the town and
part of the team so I think they'll be
fine but yeah it's a great question
because does it have to relive what
happened again and again again all year
long everywhere luckily Lakers uh buying
or selling trade deadline I hope I hope
they're buying I hope they're create I
hope they trade calculus and get a
shooter in a you know three and D guy I
think they definitely need that they're
close enough you know the window is
there for them this is probably their
best chance to win it I hope they do it
and again this goes back to you know the
man most affected by the Kobe Bryant
deaths you know was so close to him with
LA Kalinka and you know lobster
you know love is going through a
terrible terrible time and so can the
trade their lawyers even talked about
the Lakers asked them to extend the
trade deadline for them they won't do
that of course but yeah can they make a
move on that they need to make a move I
don't think they have enough right now I
don't think they have enough to beat the
Clippers to be honest with you I think
they need we need one more shooter and I
think they can and again a guy can play
defense on the wing and I think that's a
that's something that they've got to do
I believe what about the Clippers well
their whole problem is themselves if
they can and it's weird because all this
talk about log management everybody says
how it affects him in the standings it
affects him in the locker room I mean
these guys having Paul George and quiet
Leonard haven't played together very
much they haven't played together as a
team very much there's still chemistry
issues even last night they wanted to
beat San Antonio looked had to come back
and do in the last couple minutes
they've they've got to get their
chemistry issues worked out and I think
if they do that though I think they're
the best I think everybody agrees
they're the best team in town right now
because there's a deep esteem they put
the best defenses they have Patrick
Beverley which the Lakers don't have a
Patrick Beverley yeah I don't know if
Kawhi and Paul George just turn it on
automatically and have like is there low
tonight
is there gonna be load management in the
playoffs for Kawhi Leonard and or Paul
jewelry yeah no you know what I know but
but yeah I agree with you and I think
the rest of the Clippers remember this
is a team built on a fabric of hard work
and teamwork and these guys are on their
own schedules and especially kalaiy and
I think that you know on the outside
wall looking at that chicken our heads I
think on the inside that some of the
players are doing the same thing and so
I think that's an issue they've got to
get rid of I get resolved I pay what I
think one thing that we're all this load
management talk the Clippers I don't
know they're the best team in town they
better win a championship after all they
put their fans through with this you
know all the games all the games these
guys have missed because because they
keep saying well we'll wait and see what
wait and see it you'll see it'll all pay
off well let's you know I'm sure the
fans are surely hoping he'll pay off it
better pay off he's bill plasticky from
the LA Times in contributor to around
the horn before I get to the Dodgers I
saw where Vegas had the Chargers up
pretty high on
Tom Brady sweepstakes there and also
with the Super Bowl odds you know Vegas
usually knows before everybody else
knows what's your sense of Tom Brady
with the Chargers as a possibility I
just I just can't imagine and I just
can't imagine people I come here with no
I know the move into a new stadium but
they're a team without a fan base or a
team without a home
they're a team without any you know that
they played they played 16 role games
last year their players said I wrote it
everybody wrote it it's I don't I don't
see why he we want to come here I just
have no idea why he I'm sure the
Chargers would take him the they're
desperate for anything any buzz for
anything that kind of latch on to the
town and get somebody to pay attention
to him but I just don't I just think
it'd be a bad move for him I just think
it you know and there I still think and
of course you all discusses on this show
ad nauseam but I still think if you're
staying to anyway that's a chance we're
champions yet but he had the Chargers
they would love him I don't see what the
upside is for him out here I mean he's
not coming
it's like saying you're coming to LA and
then go play for the angels it's it's
it's it's and it's quite it's worse and
that's like saying you're going to el
angel place the ducts it's you know that
they you know the Chargers are not
they're not LA so I don't care where
they're what's what's a stadium they're
playing in they you know it's he's gonna
be on the road for 16 games a year and I
don't think that's the way he wants to
end his career
speaking of a star maybe leaving New
England Mookie Betts and the Dodgers I
thought the Dodgers might have needed
pitching more than another outfielder
bill but you know Mookie is a great
great player I know you get David Price
here I don't know if I want David Price
at that price but I don't want David
Potter on what they reprised at any
price and I think I think they don't
have to take him to make this deal work
you know I think they've they're
convinced and the stats will prove it
out that they're really that what's hurt
them it down the stretch the last three
years is they've added about 200 in the
last 12 series a playoff this series of
the season they were hitting they need a
stud October hitter they need a guy who
can grab the ball the guy at the top of
the order they need somebody and fence
is perfect for that he would put them
over the top and it clears the question
everybody towns asking
is will the Dodger management paid in 96
million dollars to take David Price in
the deal then the holdup right now will
they do that and I think the pressure is
on them to do that because they it
really should have had Gerrit Cole they
they get they had spent the money this
is where the richest humor baseball he
asked me they're making eight billion
dollars on TV deal they should have
spent the money to get Gary Cole they
would have had him if they had spent the
extra thirty or thirty million or so and
it's the easy saying it's not not my
money but they're making money hand over
fist over there that's your resume and
so they're fans and finally I think all
the anger over all the October
heartbreaks you know it's at first to
everybody's mad at Dave Robertson no mad
at Andrew free but now everyone's mad at
ownership and they're like spending the
money get it done now the window is
closing and if it means taking on David
prices money do it but that's the if
there's if this deals not done all
hell's gonna break loose out here
because that's the holdup is David Price
in his contract and I just say take them
put them in or just use them whenever
you however you want to use them take
them just anything to get mookie betts I
think that's gonna think the Dodgers
have to make this deal I just wondered
about that ballpark with Mookie Betts is
he catered to that ballpark oh I think
he's behind yeah I mean he's catered yes
I think I think I think he works here I
think it works it works in the outfield
the great fielder I just think it it
just gives them a you know a legitimate
this kind of last four years is second
best player in baseball to Mike Trout if
you ask me and I just got so clue that
out I just think they need that swagger
they need that stud hitter and and more
importantly it's frankly and then
whether the work in Dodger Stadium cuz
they're gonna win 96 games in Dodger
Stadium and in the regular season Ken
York in October can you get a big hit
not cooler this team could not get a big
hit to save its life in October can he
do it
good because because Cory Bellinger is
not the guy Cora Bellinger is not the
guy to get it's not gonna big on clover
player so can this guy become that bad
guy that's what they need and that's
what this would add I do think this
would you know what we are citizen for
it when they require Machado to trade to
lie on the required Darvish say okay
that puts them over the top well I think
this really does put it over the top
this would make them the world sir
favor they've got to do this deal there
they have to do it David Price be damned
just do it and the Padres sneak in and
do this no I don't I don't see why they
would be bad the guys just gonna play
their one year he's not gonna be there
more than one year they're not gonna win
anything this year they want they want
70 games last year he's gonna make them
in you know 16 20 games better the
Padres would be foolish to do this
foolishness on my child agree this yeah
just give up Padres it's their turn it's
their time finish it right now it to
finish the deal ownership anyway you'll
you'll see it's all on ownership and
then Dodgers this is a deal they have to
do that's why I'm good please you're
gonna do it thank you Bill we appreciate
it thanks for joining us yeah that's
bill plash key LA Times columnist
contributor for around the horn for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]